[Aplausos]
[Música]
ha pasado siete años desde que ella soy
comenzó a montar como las mujeres que
están cambiando el mundo y hace tres
años nos unimos a esta historia en
español
james webb entramos a lo que yo nos dice
que la liberación del prisionero pues
una bendición especial solicitando
fondos bancarios inflado la llama de gas
carbón al municipio sin itunes a adbel
innata a rafael ariza en tamaño viniendo
a la oficina y xavi denuncia white no se
pierda este programa en el que pondremos
el foco en las mujeres activistas a
quien lucha por nuestros derechos
vea nuestra edición especial sobre las
nuevas voces del feminismo en france 24
y france 24 puntocom